some parcels come through these are my
favorite kind of parcels these are books
other thing I just I'm just so obsessed
with ordering the books from Amazon and
I do read them tend to typically read
like rather than read in 10 pages a day
a lot of stuff I tend to just get like a
pet for the book alright so what I got
Manor Manor by bed Ross Julianne and
profit first feasel recommended by Sarah
to Vera Vera - Vera is my CEO over the
combination is an amazing lady if sarah
tells me to read a book i will always go
ahead and read that book so hopefully
you've got friends in your life and
success buddies that kind of or say you
got to read this book you know great to
have relationships like this profit
first fantastic really excited about
that she's been talking about this for
ages i think that's what this book is
about is rather than saying you know
your turnover or your sales - expenses
equals profit it's like it did just
spins that completely on its head it
says pay pay yourself first in your
business so it'll be your turn over why
don't even remember I need to read the
book I've not read the book well alright
cool manner I wonder why she told me to
read that has to cut the bulky and kick
ass in business and in life before doing
that let's see what else we got two more
parcels to go this is what I'm reading
at the minute people say something what
do you read well this is what I'm
reading right now obviously what I'm
about to read excited okay I couldn't
not read this one thank you by Robert
Kiyosaki I mean Robert Kiyosaki has been
talking about this book so much and even
when I interviewed him I felt big bad
actually I interviewed about a month or
two ago and this is like his new book
and I hadn't read it how awful is that
but I have read loads of clear sack
these books and
yeah looks like quite a thick book but I
mean Kiyosaki he's like a walking legend
when it comes to personal finance so
fake money fake teachers fake assets
love it that's gonna be really
interesting thank you
I don't let you know how get on with
these books one more parcel what am i
reading let's find out Oh whew here okay
so yeah James can't I had a conversation
with James this is Oscar James comp book
this news story this is advice had a
conversation phone call B James a couple
weeks ago and I'm gonna be meeting up
with James actually I'm meeting James
next month and I just thought before I
meet him because he's also going to be
coming on my YouTube channel and stuff
for me and I have to just read his books
otherwise I think he would just be
disrespectful to me in without reading
books so look forward to really get my
teeth into this file in a bit more about
into his journey love James Carr I've
real respect for all of the Dragons on
Dragon's Den marketing marketing is
everything 1 million followers how I
built a massive social following in 30
days see right now I'm unjust I have a
hundred thousand subscribers on YouTube
I want to get that up to a million so
happy to read this book to see how that
can happen so that's what I'm reading
right now comment below let me know what
you're reading as well and I've just
literally got back from a crash course
right now so it's really like I'm really
tired by the store I was wanting to open
these past off the project bed thought
I'd do a quick video thanks for watching
peace out you're awesome
[Music]